welcome to this video playing w I am
holy mess from other by john w i am in
mira a year 11 13 times are there by
John champion okay that's quite a lot
nothing that I'm going to accomplish
okay okay we should before check we get
the the bull go again okay janitor I
need to take em before Queenie force is
coming with some some ugly consequences
yeah that's a typically solid position
for this opening or she allows me to to
block the queenside that's a bit a bit
surprising and I don't mind this tempo
as well it's it's not a great position
of the bishop but but okay can play it
may be here activating this piece don't
mind to trade it and I have 9075 coming
ok might be three not the most
sophisticated idea ever but if it works
yeah I really like the position because
I I have a good good control on the
queenside why does not going to play
before or something like that and even
black can consider to play b5 later
maybe it will be eight and then be five
I can try that why not okay I can also
keep it on the board but i don't think
so i should get ahead with with my
player could also played on the kingside
both walser was possible
okay double double on the B file or not
maybe double
another night on c4 is a good a good
defensive piece at the moment but I
might be able to to exchange it later
wow that's like that it looks like a
weakening a white terribly ok you can
Queen g5 seems seems possible what to
see what she playing then grouped
euphoria
okay let's keep keep their pond it's a
hmm don't see something great but it
looks it looks very questionable because
basically everything's week now efore
III e2f for whites position is full of
holes but I don't really see at the
moment how to exploit it yeah maybe I
need you need a light the night 35 to
get rid of the same defender of be too
not clear not clear to me maybe I also
should have played Queen f7 first trying
to and it was may be interesting trying
to try to provoke a form to have 93
available may be a good idea
yeah she's spending a ton of time him
not quite sure for what what what
there's something specific to be
calculated don't know okay maybe first I
can start with that it's probably not
measuring very much maybe is
can take 25 I can take be to whom yeah I
guess be to was more important
taking d5 I can take it as she's got
Queenie eight major but that's cool
that's cute okay
takes 95 there was Queenie ate meat
great but I still should have the better
coordination here and some attacking
ideas 95 fe5 this d5 hanging and rugby
one threatened with Queen f1 coming the
rook is very awkward only for in case of
a CAPTCHA lv5 ok can take here or queen
g 6 26 runs into 97 mm-hmm not good and
taking him
there's no big threat thread or anything
else oh okay maybe just get the King out
of it between h5 may be attacking you
too
time warning why she's defending this
well
up to here I guess check check on you
for maybe
mmm didn't see that one Wow awkward
check check check
check what forfeits she could have ended
total moves I mean she made a ton of
moves with the clock basically already
already run out whom this looked very
very good after a four but I didn't
really managed to put it away FR looked
looked very weakening or don't I don't
manage to go down so here so let's check
f form you're taking is certainly right
and maybe f6 was really the problem by
the computers just just much better here
what is playing g 6 + f5 is much better
of course young this allows 90 form
possibly this is a passive move it's
still good yeah but it's not it's not as
convincing it always gives me some
advantage but I hear Niger 6 was strong
why exactly that one those little
tactics are cute i hear a i have this
one check winning the rook in the corner
on be one I took here and now it's
absolutely not clear it still looks a
bit awkward for white but there is no
win and computer agrees only gives me
slide action now it's getting a bit
bigger yeah check mirchi I'm winning
yeah that was that was tough but f-for
was really not a good idea it's
weakening weakening too much squares and
and pawns okay thanks for watching